let's just uh let's hop into this first
story we got a lot to talk about check
this out first from
hero7 live local in depth they say
police arrest pulley up man for starting
large wildfire so there's a lot we got
to break down first they don't say who
the person is
and they don't say it was intentionally
lit all right
they say pulit police and state troopers
arrested a 36 year old polyup man
wednesday for allegedly starting a large
brush fire which temporarily shut down
state route 167
and several ramps near meridian avenue a
man with the exact same name as the one
police arrested
recorded a facebook live of that fire
saying he reported it to first
responders
and of the same age so i wonder if it's
the same person
police told cairo 7 that they were made
aware of the facebook live which showed
his interaction with officers after the
arrest
after the arrest whoa he says i'm out
here on 167 right now
the man said in the stream looks like a
fire literally just started
and i just rolled up on it and it looks
like it's going crazy
i'm here with the police and they're
talking to me about it because i just
called it in
now that's the gist of that story all
right we got to read more because they
mentioned there was
a person was seen intentionally lighting
a fire somewhere else so first of all
a lot of people are saying it's
intentional we don't know that but we do
have this we i think we do have the
tweet here check this out
trooper ryan burke tweeted joint team
effort
wsp 5pd and polyetpd just arrested a 36
year old
pulley up resident i think i hope okay
people are correcting us here
it's pugilip that's not even an element
yeah there's the l comes later
i'm just trying
he was caught in the median setting a
fire he is currently on his way to jail
great job everybody play stupid games
all right now hold on
they said he was setting a fire that
sounds like arson yeah or sure does is
that not the definition of arson
i guess well the definition is the
criminal act of deliberately setting
fire to property
oh there you go it's not property
because it's literally property
okay you can't like own property man you
know we bought
property therefore you can't have
arsenal dude fire is like
mass destruction yeah like this is if
someone set off a nuclear bomb they'd go
to jail for
like much worse these wildfire like if
yeah dude this guy was like
that they're lucky it didn't spread
because you look at this photo and that
was a huge that's a big fire
it's not the biggest but it was a large
fire and i gotta say right now look
they're saying
he was setting a fire now that's that
they got to be very careful about what
they say
so all we know right now officially
confirmed some people are saying
they're posting some photos of what what
appears to be
like court or like police records i
could not verify them
in these records it says something like
uh reckless second-degree
fire or something yeah which may have
been what's reckless flicking a
cigarette
right something like that i can't
confirm that's real though so all we
have right now is this cop saying
that he was setting a fire this sounds
like so let's let's talk about who this
guy is first
we had this tweet from katie davis court
she says puyol up arrested jeffrey
accord in relation to the arson along
167 highway
in 2014 during an anti-police protest
accord was charged with possession
of a concealed weapon without permit
carrying a knife and a legal possession
of fireworks
i wonder what the fireworks were for
well she posted this video
she says earlier in the day jeffrey
accord called in his own arson pou you
love pd
he even filled himself at the fires on
facebook live after questioning him
the puyola police department arrested
him on suspicion that he started the
fires
so i actually i went to his facebook
page sure enough
there's the guy and yes i'm legit
like we confirmed he posted this
so here's a story from the local news
sale times when you google search this
guy's name that's what you get
they say jeffrey allen accord 31 was
charged wednesday in seattle municipal
court
with possession of a concealed pistol
without a permit carrying a dangerous
knife and a legal possession of
fireworks
they say that he was at monday's
ferguson protest in seattle
had a cache of weapons i guess it's a
cash cash we're just talking about the
cashier
of weapons including a handgun knife
shotgun semi-automatic rifle ammunition
and powerful fireworks
they go on to mention a court of
covington was among five people arrested
during the march
and protest monday in seattle after a
missouri grand jury decided not to
indict a police officer for fatally
shooting an
armed black man protesters marched from
west lake park to capitol hill
and some later clashed with police and
climbed onto interstate 5 blocking
traffic
during the violence fireworks were fired
into the sky and police say they were
pelted with rocks bottles and canned
food
seattle police chief kathleen o'toole
said it's unclear why accord had the
weapons
i don't know what his plans were but
it's obviously of great concern
that somebody would come to an event in
seattle with those weapons readily
available okay
so let's go back to the official
confirmed source from from hero7
and they say the guy said i'm out here
on one to seven now
i'm here with the police that's a quote
they also say a man with the exact same
name was arrested
i can't imagine that someone of the
exact same name was wandering around
very unlikely yeah just like two guys
same age
multiple dimension stuff so i think for
legal reasons they're saying it that way
but when you watch the actual stream you
put out that's that's a quote
like they've quoted what he said this is
the guy i think it is fair to say
beyond a reasonable doubt this is the
guy now whether or not he's guilty of
intentionally setting fires until proven
guilty so is this the same guy that at
the end of that article they said
another another guy was standing on the
side of the road lighting a fire
somewhere somewhere else oh it's a
different guy we got a bunch of stories
man dude
yeah this is crazy this is crazy i think
that's what we have
in terms of just like confirming this so
i want to make sure there's a few things
that are very very very clear
before we start getting into the next
bit because there's more dude
the important thing to talk about is
first of all
it sounds like arson from the police i'm
i'm just i'm gonna put
these these important disclaimers out we
don't know for sure
they did not literally confirm the guy's
name and it may not be that this guy is
like a dedicated anti-for dude right
this is another important factor is
just because he got arrested in 2014
doesn't mean he's like going out to all
these protests we don't know maybe maybe
he was could just be a reckless guy
right he could be just a firebug he's a
dude who likes to cause trouble
so he brought fireworks and guns to a
protest for fun
i looked i looked at this guy's
information i did not see anything that
would suggest he's a dedicated die-hard
leftist or anything like that
however he's i i i have to err on the
side of he's been to these protests he's
brought weapons to these protests
there's other videos there's more videos
that people have pulled from his
facebook
where he's at protests and he's young
recently actually
there was a he he's at the george floyd
protest and he's yelling about you know
six feet apart and he's laughing about
it all right
yeah yeah that was very strange well
actually i got to stop there they're
alleging that's the case i'm gonna be
very careful with here
they don't know it's him so some people
have posted videos saying
here he is we pulled this from his
facebook and it's him laughing and
filming himself it looks like him
but i want to be very careful because i
think you know this is already making
the rounds this story
and people are saying it's legit it's
confirmed it's not it's not
it's not so it seems like this guy does
support black lives matter
he's protested with them before and he's
i have to assume he's probably done it
more than once because we've seen
you know potential evidence there's more
than one so there you go there you go
all right this is what uh i want to make
sure it's clear
the bigger issue at play i believe is
that if you do a google search
of wildfire and climate change
you'll see all of these stories where
they say new york times
the straightforward link between climate
change and california's fires
yet perhaps i'm not discrediting that
i'm just saying that there's a big
narrative that everything we're seeing
is
you know wildfire wildfires and weather
extremes it's not coincidence it's
climate change
wildfires are worsening the way we
manage them isn't keeping pace
california governor and wildfires no
patience for climate change deniers
well i certainly think that's a thing
that's an issue if they don't address
the arsonists
then i think you're going to get a group
of people who say it's not climate
change it's arson
and then you're going to get a group of
people who don't even know the arson is
happening
it's it's both right but it's totally
possible yeah
i think i think it's fair to say there's
a happy medium
well i shouldn't say is it horrifying
terrible
not a happy medium it's you've got
people who want to start fires
and there's conditions being met because
of climate change that make the fire
substantially worse
but you gotta address the arsonist check
this out they also go on to say after
this
in graham a person was seen
intentionally setting a fire
to a field in front of a business in the
10 400 block
of 2929 southeast early wednesday
morning
this was 100 percent intentional there
is zero doubt said jonas petit
the owner of vac tech septic and water
surveillance shows the suspect drive
up dumping gasoline and a match
setting fire to dry grass next to the
business
pierce county detectives have the video
which doesn't show
the suspect or the vehicle but petit
says it does show
a random act of potential devastation
you watch the flame
and then where he flips it and it just
goes boom big ball of flame he said
firefighters and a lack of wind kept the
flames from destroying their business
only a few yards beyond the burn
if the wind would have been blowing like
it was the other night
you wouldn't have stopped this it would
have added up onto the other fire in
graham petit said
the area is only a couple miles from the
gram fire which is destroyed which
destroyed eight homes and they go on a
show
the trooper of course so there's uh
there's more men
we got another one give it to me we got
another one from kiro seven news
seriously look at this this is from
today
second man arrested for intentionally
starting brush fire in pierce county
yup this is parkland washington troopers
at the washington state patrol on
thursday
said they have arrested a second person
for intentionally starting a brush fire
in pierce county
troopers said someone saw a man setting
fire to grass with a match
near state route 512 and state route 7
and called police
troopers arrived at the scene chased the
man and took him into custody
wow tuesday thursday's arrest comes one
day after a 36 year old pouyo lip man
was arrested
for allegedly starting a large brush
fire which temporarily shut down 167
that's the story we're just talking
about
fire danger remains very high across
washington due to low humidity and high
temperatures
more than 480 000 acres in washington
have burned since monday
so here's another tweet from trooper
ryan burke we got another one great job
trooper moorefield
a pedestrian decided to match light the
grass
at sr512 and sr-7 citizen observed it
and alerted 9-1-1
after a short foot chase one is in
custody and on the way to jail
what if i told you we had more tell me
but wait there's more
arsonists for some reason are trying to
just
destroy everything it's copy cat
criminality no i don't know man are
these like it's like the joker
or it's the collective consciousness is
sparking you know literally
yeah bad bad analogy i don't know man i
think it's
you take uh a large population of people
and there's a standard deviation you
know of people who happen to be
arsonists so like if for every thousand
people you have one arsonist what
happens when you have a million people
you have a thousand arsonists
and then they're all going around yeah i
mean that's the that's the assumption
scaling up right so maybe it's like
every one in ten thousand
one in one even if it's one in a million
in these areas you'll have four or five
and when they see
stories online about it then they're
like oh i could go do that i mean that's
a crazy
if you see read an article how easy it
is to go out there and destroy
property you're not you don't have to
have to stick around you know you
it's just i mean look at this this is
terrorism to me and i don't like to use
that word a lot
it's it's i don't i don't know i don't
know terrorism is like
there's a there's a goal a political
goal this is terrifying though
this could destroy everything thousands
of people
like as yeah their homes their lives
their animals
yeah the roads the the pro everything
the whole forest the ecosystem yeah so i
don't know if it's terrorism
but uh i just got i got i got i got
another story man
go for it what are they what is this
look at this so we have two different
locations in oregon and not seattle now
we have eugene
yeah so no the those two were in
washington weren't they yeah yeah
now we have one in eugene a man arrested
on arson allegation in wildfire west of
eugene deputies say
look at this photo man the sweet creek
milepost ii fire seen in an undated
photo
so is this is this is that's not it that
that's not it
why not why because it's that's an
undated photo they're
they're talking about like a lot like
maybe a large fire in the area
i don't know why undated photo just
means they don't know when it was taken
so it could be the fire maybe so a forty
think that would be dated though sorry
i'll
read a 44 year old man was arrested
tuesday on suspicion of arson in a
wildfire
that has burned nearly 400 acres and
prompted evacuations west of eugene
elias newton pendergrass is accused of
first degree arson in the sweet creek
milepost ii fire so that's it
which covers 382 acres near the
community of mapleton pendlegrass a
mapleton resident
is being held in the lane county jail
the county sheriff's office didn't
provide details about the arson
allegation
in a news release tuesday afternoon
officials have previously said
several fires started sunday afternoon
and that they were managing the blazes
as a single fire
some area residents are still under
evacuation while others have been told
to be ready to uh ready ready or set to
leave
the blaze is estimated to be 15
contained fire officials said early
early wednesday
so what do you think happens when these
stories start you know flying off the
shelves the virality
people i mean we're we're in a hot
political environment
it is it's 2020 the election is less
than you know two months away
and everybody is pointing the fingers
which is why we end up with a headline
like you know blm leftists arrested for
starting a fire
for one to what degree are they an
active you know they are they've
supported and protested for them so i
think that's fair
but uh they're not necessarily an
organizer was it actually arson i don't
know i don't know
but we're already seeing the
ramifications of this and here we go
check us out
justin yao he's at p documentarians
and he's a freelance journalist tweeted
we were approached by an
armed group telling us to leave they are
wary of outsiders based on rumors of
arsonists setting fires in the area
so here's the image you can see fire
season in effect all burning prohibited
fire danger listed as extreme and
there's there's
we can see one guy right here who's
armed this guy doesn't appear to be
maybe he's got a handgun or something
this guy right here might actually be
armed also we can't see we don't know
for sure
but the way you know what you know what
i think when i see this they don't want
outsiders coming in there's major fires
and a massive natural disaster occurring
why should i be upset by them saying i
don't think so so what what occurred to
me when i saw this picture was that
these guys don't want people to come in
and start fires
i know it's that simple right yeah and
i'm not convinced firing guns is a good
way to
keep fires from starting but i mean they
probably think it's better than nothing
they're like just like stay out stay out
of the national forest or whatever
so if this was any other disaster would
we would we be surprised
you know if there was like a flood or a
hurricane or tornado and then you know
there were armed guards like we don't
want looters we don't want
no i mean no especially with the flood
if they're armed guards i think they'll
be very normal
so so the responses to this are
are really interesting some of them and
it's kind of it's kind of random they're
saying
uh patriot prayer proud boys extremists
like far right chandler pappas are
spreading the rumors on social media
and so this is turning into a partisan
political issue oh my gosh why um
because i just started a stream with a
title saying blm leftist oh yeah
okay cause because it's it's the lens
that which everything is is being based
right now
and for me i guess i i'll fully i'll
fully admit to there being an issue of
like
doing this live stream from this
headline but
it's because i i see these posts getting
a ton of traction
a lot of articles are popping up people
were contacting me be like yo look what
they're doing
like antifa is going around setting
fires on purpose and i'm like okay maybe
we can we i can i first i started
researching it took me a little bit
to actually um uh confirm a lot of what
they were what they were saying
and uh i've excluded some of what i
couldn't confirm
but it looks legit like this guy was a
protester
but people are taking it to you know
like
i don't know taking it pretty far he was
a radical protester whether or not
whatever political party that kind of
radical protest is dangerous where you
take
guns weapons and fireworks to uh to a
rally yeah well i'm trying to set stuff
on fire like they did at ted wheeler's
house like
two weeks ago trying to set the guy's
house on fire that was that was a
complex a whole building with like 100
people in it
114 residences or something they're
going to burn them to death that was
their plan
yeah it's a good plan i don't know i
know i shouldn't laugh but it's like
it's that that's that yeah dude
well it's it's tough right because
i i don't want to come out and be like
people listen the anti-farts are going
around they're burning down forests
like you've got people who broke through
the windows
and then someone lit a bunch of
newspapers on fire and threw on the
first floor of ted wheeler's building oh
whoa
so naturally you can say they were
trying to burn the place down right
yeah or what if they were just morons it
was newspaper so like what are you going
to get done
it's like a stack though
but that's not a good thing to do right
now yeah seriously
you get your point across in many other
ways write a song
but maybe they don't want the point
across maybe they want to kill people
why though
well so so this is what i'm trying to
say like i'm really reluctant to be like
they were trying to kill people
but they were trying to burn them
weren't they trying to kill people in
their house
yeah yeah it seems like they're trying
to kill everyone like they're that angry
that they're gonna at least negligence
but i wonder because here's why i'm
reluctant to actually go that far
because
i've talked about what happens when they
show up when the mob shows up to your
house
and what happens is one person like
here's what happens at ted wheeler's
place
someone runs up and throws a brick
through the window and it shatters and
then he runs away
and then another other people see him
when he's running up to it before he
throws it they're
they're like oh i'm gonna walk up too he
throws the brick it shatters and runs
and then someone looks through the
window someone people behind him see him
going towards the window like he's going
to go in
and they go in and one by one it's like
an avalanche
each individual is just doing a little a
little incremental thing and leaving but
the whole group is moving
and then all sudden they're inside then
someone looks over and they see like you
know something they take it
and then people see them grabbing
something so they all start grabbing
stuff and then some dude chucks the
flaming debris that's someone else
lights debris on fire
someone sees it and chucks it into the
building and runs off so they're all
doing a little bit to like
stack up you know i think these people
are desensitized because of
i don't know why because they've been
exposed as a five-year-old to
pornography or
violent video games in their minds i can
light stuff on fire and then reload the
game later if it doesn't work out
interesting i don't know i think there's
no there's no punishment
i think people like these you know it's
crazy is like aren't they scared of
going to prison
you know i don't know it almost like
they're not well i mean the people that
were faking
i mean i don't know that they were
faking uh having what was a seizures
yeah they might have been afraid of
going and that's why they were facing i
don't know man
it's little kids having temper tantrums
that's what it seems like so so the
context here is yeah like during the
riots there were people who were
uh when when they get arrested they have
these hollywood style seizures
and anybody who's actually ever actually
witnessed a seizure is like that is not
a seizure
you are acting something you saw in a
movie teaser's not dramatic
yeah yeah so like there's like a video
of and but the the emts and the medics
will hold their heads properly
just because they're like you know and
it's really funny man i i
it's so it's so annoying you got this
video of an actual emt
with armor and like you know his city
you sanctioned gear
he's holding the man's head doing
everything properly because
this is the basis of what i was trained
when i did the first aid training and
hustle environment stuff
and the activities are yelling you need
to turn him on his side you need to turn
his head
what are you doing and i'm like why are
you random protester
yelling at the emergency medical
professional what they should be doing
with someone who might be having a
seizure wow
because they saw it on tv i think
probably yeah and that's why the fake
people are doing the fake seizures
because they're acting like what they
saw on tv
man it's like why are they allowing
these people to do it
is the bigger yeah it's like they're
they don't want to shut it down without
allowing them because it's united states
you want to give people the right to
protest and if that means that you trip
and fall and break someone's arm
while you're protesting so be it but
then now they're like
aggravating like they're they're
attempting to destroy people's arms and
and
buildings the police are under the
protesters oh yeah for sure and at that
point i don't know why they're letting
it happen
i don't know man i'd i'd love to get
conspiratorial
do it well like just like the the the
the the
uh the district attorneys in washington
are are in on anti-fun
won't charge them yeah that'd be crazy
like we it's not even conspiratorial
they've said that much like we're not
going to charge them
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you